who has the iPad the first one is this
picture this is Kanye and I at a
friend's wedding in Miami we went around
the whole wedding reception taking
photos of all of our friends and
different couples okay this picture is
me and Emily we took this picture in the
bathroom at the Staples Center at a
Justin Bieber concert I posted a nude
selfie and I put the black sensor bars
over it and Emily was like one of the
people to really stick up for me and
post something really sweet we just
thought it was funny and we went in the
bathroom and took a picture here is the
original picture I was dyeing my hair
back dark the next day and so I wanted
to capture my blonde moments as much as
possible
I of course just took selfies nude
selfies in the bathroom this is a selfie
that I took with Hillary Clinton and
Kanye and we were at a benefit for her
and no one could have phones and they
said but Kim you could bring a phone and
take a selfie so this is at our favorite
restaurant Nobu and this was one of my
first pictures with my mom and Caitlyn
together we were celebrating someone's
birthday I think Kylie's this is my
husband and my daughter we were baby
shopping with some friends of ours in
like a baby store and of course I
couldn't find them for a little bit and
they were upstairs sleeping on the baby
furniture this is when Kanye Anna got
engaged
and we are in San Francisco at the
baseball field and I didn't know that
like in the dugouts my whole family and
all my friends were in there afterwards
they all ran out and it was just such a
cool unforgettable birthday this is a
photo of my husband and I at our wedding
in Italy I just love all of these photos
and how they were shot and we have the
most amazing photo album this is my mom
upside down on a stripper pole I think
it's really fitting to her personality I
did not tell her before I posted this
she has a really good sense of humor so
she thought it was funny
this was a Polaroid that Nicole Richie
and I took for her 13th birthday party
that I threw for her at Michael
Jackson's
house and I just don't know what's
funnier like how we look or what we're
doing or the fact that I even found this
photo I got a little cat Kanye got one
for me and it was like a miniature
Persian cat it was so cute I love
showing these photos of my to my
daughter because she loves cats
this is me and Mason playing tennis he
must have been like 1 and 1/2 here
I don't know if I have like a headband
on sunglasses he has sunglasses I don't
really know what's going on this was my
very first Instagram picture so I was
just getting my hair and makeup done
about to film something for my show and
I took my very first Instagram picture
let's see what the date is if it has one
oh no date just 220 weeks ago can anyone
tell me one 220 weeks ago is I cannot so